BOTTLE OF WINE, A SHOE,
AND A WALL
AND START BANGING.
THIS IS WINE EXPERT
STEPHEN CRONK.
HIS VIDEO RACKED UP
AN INCREDIBLE 11 MILLION VIEWS.
CORK BEGINS TO POP UP.
DO THE REST BY HAND.
ET VOILà.
THIS IS SO INGENIOUS.
Narrator: HOW IS STEPHEN
USING THIS CORKSHOE?
ET VOILà.
STEPHEN MOVES THE BOTTLE
THROUGH THE AIR,
GIVING IT MOMENTUM.
AND START BANGING.
WHAT HE WANTS TO DO
IS APPLY A FORCE ON THE BOTTLE
THAT WILL BE TRANSFERRED
TO THE CORK
AND MOVE THE CORK
OUT OF THE BOTTLE.
IF THE FORCE IS TOO GREAT,
THE BOTTLE WILL BREAK.
AND SO HE USES A SHOE,
WHICH SOFTENS THE BLOW
AND EXTENDS THE TIME
OF THE IMPACT.
IT'S THOUGHT THAT ANOTHER EFFECT
MIGHT BE
HELPING STEPHEN AS WELL.
AND THIS IS THE EFFECT
OF CAVITATION.
WHEN THE BOTTLE MAKES
CONTACT WITH THE WALL,
THE WINE NOW MOVES FORWARD
WITH A HIGH VELOCITY.
THIS COMPRESSES AN AIR POCKET,
CREATING AN AREA OF LOW PRESSURE
IN THE NECK OF THE BOTTLE,
WHERE BUBBLES OF VACUUM FORM
CALLED CAVITATION BUBBLES.
AND AS THESE CAVITATION BUBBLES
IMPLODE,
A LARGE AMOUNT OF ENERGY
IS RELEASED.
AND THIS MEANS THAT IT APPLES
A PRESSURE TO THE CORK,
AND WITH EACH STRIKE, THE CORK
GETS PUSHED OUT A LITTLE BIT.
ET VOILà.
Narrator: BUT THIS TECHNIQUE
ISN'T A SHOO-IN.
GET IT WRONG AND...
[ WOMAN SHOUTS ]
ALL THAT WINE.
Narrator: SO UNLESS YOU WANT TO
RISK YOUR ROSé,
DON'T TRY THIS ONE AT HOME.